ja wir haben gestern im duell im trier
sagt immer du wir haben gestern im trio
das wort islamismus auch mal wieder
nicht gehört islamistischer terror
islamistisches gedankengut
islamistische ideologie spielte dort
keine rolle obwohl es ein thema ist was
unzählige menschen bewegt gute nachricht
ist es gibt noch islamismus und
islamisten und islamistische ideologie
im öffentlich rechtlichen fernsehen
allerdings nicht als frage an die
kandidaten sondern als moderatorin einer
neuen
wissenschaftssendung da gibt es ein
bemerkenswertes video über die neue
moderatorin von quarks die sendung für
wissenschaft folgt der wissenschaft
hören wir so gerne beim
öffentlich-rechtlichen und in dieses
kurze video wo sie uns den dschihad
erklärt und warum der ge hat der heilige
krieg der auf der welt tausende und
10.000 hunderttausende opfer gekostet
hat bei terroranschlag der eigentlich
gar nichts schlimmes ist das gucken uns
mal ganz kurz an
sie warnt vor anschlägen den obama
schwadronieren über einen heiligen krieg
und der muslime angestrebte sieg über
ihre zivilisation
und sind dabei ganz nah bei jenen vor
dem sie waren dabei ist sie hart für
mich eine vision vom sich selbst
hinterfragen und davon ideale zu tragen
sie hatte seine vision
das klingt so nett das klingt so
freundlich das klingt so schön nach
ausgestrahlter hand das ist nichts
anderes als relativismus einer der
tödlichsten ideologien die es auf der
welt gibt und die wird uns jetzt
präsentiert werfen sollte es noch
überraschend von unseren gebührengeldern
von unseren gebührengeldern müssen wir
jetzt für eine wissenschafts moderatorin
bezahlen die hier in berlin wir sehen
das foto der gerade auf einer israel
hass und vernichtungs demo dem al kuds
tag zum beispiel demonstriert hat und
sich von dieser ideologie auch in keiner
weise bisher distanziert und hier ist
der interessanteste punkt wenn eine
islamistin ein wissenschafts format
moderiert im islam wenn man ihn streng
gläubig wie islamisten das tun und
politisch interpretiert kann es
eigentlich gar keine wissenschaft geben
warum weil bei wissenschaft per
definition da gar nichts rauskommen darf
was dem heiligen koran widersprechen
könnte das heißt für islamisten warum
leben islamisten so rückständig wie sie
leben weil sie wissenschaft weil sie auf
klärung all das nicht haben weil sie all
das nicht zugelassen haben umso absurder
dass wir jetzt gezwungen werden mit
unseren gebühren dafür zu bezahlen dass
eine islamistin jetzt beim öffentlich
rechtlichen fernsehen quarks beim wdr
ein wissenschafts format moderiert fans
noch einmal lernen diese demonstration
von 2014 gespielt in berlin haben eine
sehr große rolle worum geht es da der da
auf die straße wm hat sich angeschlossen
beim al kuds tag dem sogenannten al kuds
tag geht es sozusagen
darum dass in sehr vielen fällen
radikale muslime und islamisten davon
träumen israel von der landkarte zu
tilgen und nach jerusalem wieder
einzuziehen jerusalem wieder zu ihrer
hauptstadt zu machen das ist sozusagen
die botschaft dass er kurz zeit wir
hören da immer wieder israelfeindliche
parolen
so sehr dass sich immer wieder die
behörden mit der frage beschäftigt haben
darf man diese demonstration überhaupt
noch zu lassen die wdr moderatorin
findet da offenbar ganz klar ja das ist
das umfeld in dem sie sich bewegen
möchte meine meinung jemand der auf
demonstrationen sich bewegt die zur
auslöschung israels aufrufen hat im
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk
finanziert von öffentlich-rechtlichen
gebühren von unseren gebühren einfach
mal rein gar nichts zu suchen und schon
gar nicht sollte er das thema oder sie
das thema wissenschaft vertreten denn
der islamismus ist die wissenschaft
feindliche ideologie auf dieser welt
[Musik]